hello my name is alvin and today i'll be
showing you guys my recipe for the best
fudgy brownies ever
[Music]
so box mix brownies they're great
there's nothing against them they're
awesome but the thing is i wanted
something that was a little bit
different i didn't want the recipe to be
just something you could get out of a
box i want the funniest brownies ever i
want a lot of chocolate in there i want
it to be warm and gooey when you eat it
i want people to take a bite and be like
oh damn this fudgy af so i set off to
make the fudgiest brownies ever it
requires a lot of chocolate which is a
great thing and i think the most
important thing is that you make sure
that all of your ingredients are evenly
combined make sure that your eggs are
actually whisked a little bit more than
usual because you want to beat a little
bit of air into them to get that really
silky texture that was one thing that i
learned from testing was that if you
beat your eggs a little bit more than
normal you're going to get a lot
creamier sort of base that will make the
brownie a lot fudgier
another thing i would say is that don't
use just any chocolate bar you find at
the store try to make sure you get
really good chocolate because it will
make the difference you will taste the
difference and try to get a little bit
extra because i always found myself
eating at least half a bar before the
recipe was even done so definitely have
some extra chocolate on hand to snack on
because you're gonna need it
i really think that people love baking
brownies i think it's such a fun
activity baking is something that
innately requires you to go hang out
with a friend like i really wanted a
recipe that people could use as a way to
invite other people to hang out with
them i like being able to see these nice
gooey pools of chocolate on top so i'm
gonna save some chocolate and also put
some chunks on top of the brownie at the
end because i think when it comes out of
the oven you know like this is a legit
brownie this didn't come from a box this
came from your own hands and your
friends are going to go crazy and people
are going to want you to share but i
don't want you to share it even though
if you want to share because i ate the
whole tray one time and i did not regret
a single thing you want to make sure
that your brownies are baked but not
over baked because when you take it
right out of the oven it might seem like
a little soft in the center not
everything's set and that's okay because
there's a lot of chocolate in there and
that's going to be melted at that point
what you want to do which would be the
probably the hardest part to do in this
entire recipe is to wait you need to
wait for it to cool down completely
because even when it cools down
completely the chocolate won't harden if
it's really good chocolate it there
should be some gooeyness some liquidity
as it cools so even when you cut into it
and it's not warm anymore you'll still
have these nice gooey pools of chocolate
it's your recipe you can do whatever you
want with it you can add nuts you can
add caramel you can add whatever you
like just be sure that once you put more
toppings in you're going to need to bake
it for a little bit longer because now
you're preventing the batter from rising
and cooking as fast as it usually would
so if you add something in just bake it
a little more and honestly brownies are
great no matter what if you want to be a
little fancy and you have some coarse or
flaky sea salt on hand sprinkle a little
bit of salt on the brownies while
they're still hot so the salt becomes a
part of the brownie as it cools and when
you cut it that salt is going to be this
really nice touch that counteracts the
flavor and the sweetness of the
chocolate
[Music]
make sure you pour yourself a really
nice glass of cold milk because you
can't have brownies without milk just
like cookies i love this recipe i think
it's a great base recipe for any brownie
that you want to make so if you do make
it if you have a variation on it if you
add crazy things in i want to know too
so let me know post in the comments and
i want to see your stuff i love to see
when people make my recipes so
happy baking
[Music]
you